[موسيقى]
منذ كم اسبوع تم طرح هذا السؤال؟
إذا سئل، بالتأكيد التحالف الوطني
يمكننا أن نقول، لأن التحالف الوطني
6 عناصر مختلفة مرئية على الطاولة
يتكون من الحزب المكون الرئيسي
عناصر من حزب الشعب الجمهوري والحزب الصالح المتبقي
عدد كبير جدًا من الأصوات كنسبة مئوية صغيرة
الأحزاب السياسية التي لا تتوافق هناك
إنها موجودة وغير مرئية
كان من الممكن القول أنه كان هناك تحالف لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
يمكن فتح الطريق، ولكن عندما جئت
في هذه المرحلة، في الأسابيع الأخيرة، الجمهورية
كانت هناك أيضًا بعض التغييرات في التحالف
ويضاف إلى المعادلة طرف اسمه هدى
انضم وأصبح زعيم حزب العدالة والتنمية
سيتم اختيار هدى فاري من القوائم
جماعة تربطها بحزب الله
هناك، وهنا، في الواقع، الجمهورية
بعض الانتقادات للتحالف
حدث
[موسيقى]
تحالف وطني بكل معنى الكلمة
إنه تحالف مناهض لأردوغان، وهذا يكفي.
حتى يتمكن أردوغان من الرحيل وحتى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
في حملاتهم
من قبل ناخبيها ووكالاتها
نهاية غير أنيقة وغير محترمة للغاية
باستخدام تعبيرات سيئة للغاية، وهذا هو،
وطالما أن أردوغان يغادر، فإننا نصوت أيضًا لصالح السترة.
نحن نصوت مثلما نصوت للزجاجة
ولذلك فإن التحالف الوطني مضاد
إنه تحالف أردوغان، فما الذي يهم أردوغان؟
ما تفعله هو في صناعة الدفاع
تحركاتهم وتصرفاتهم من أجل الوطن
التكنولوجيا في عمله
التطورات والاستثمارات ليس لها أهمية
لا، هذه الحكومة أيضاً لديها أخطاء.
هذه الحكومة أيضا لديها حقائقها، ولكن
من أجل التحالف الوطني، منفضة سجائري
ويبدو أنهم ينفذون السياسة الخاطئة.
هناك انتقادات
[موسيقى]
يوجد اليوم أكثر من 120 حزبًا سياسيًا
في تركيا، لا يوجد سوى مكان واحد في ماضي تركيا.
حزبين، على الأكثر 3 أطراف 4
الطرف كنا نتحدث عن هذه الآن
إلى جانب الائتلافات
عدد الأحزاب في البرلمان
عندما ننظر إليها، هناك الكثير من الألوان
نحن نرى التنوع في الناخبين الأتراك.
عند التصويت في الانتخابات، ما دام أردوغان
دعوهم يذهبون ولا تتسامحوا مع أي من تصرفات أردوغان.
لن يهتم بمن سيتحالف معه.
سواء كان في خروف سيء أم لا
لن يهتم بشكل خاص بحرية التعبير
أولئك الذين يعطون الأولوية لمزيد من الديمقراطية
أولئك الذين يريدون المزيد من الحرية
السياسة ضد السياسة الاقتصادية
خرج الناس بسهولة بالغة
سوف يدعم التحالف
[موسيقى]
الخبرة الإدارية للتحالف الشعبي
نعم، فمن الواضح أن الاقتصاد الأخير
هناك بعض الأخطاء في سياساتهم وهذا
تنتج AK في الواقع أحجامًا كبيرة للجمهور
ومن الآن فصاعدا، سيقوم الحزب بزيارة تركيا
هناك أيضًا مشكلة في الإدارة
لن يحدث، ولكن سيكون هناك اختناق اقتصادي وهذا
الاستمرار في السياسات الخاطئة
في حال أصبح انعكاس الحلقة أكثر
إذا حدث ذلك، فإنه سيكون لا يطاق
قد يصل إلى مرحلة حيث الحكومة
قد يكون هناك انسداد في تحالف الأمة
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالتحالف الوطني
الأول يسقطه بسبب قلة الخبرة
لكن عندما جاء التحالف الوطني كانت النتيجة صفراً.
لأنه ليس هناك ما يضمن أنه سيكون هناك فساد
في الواقع، لقد كانت في المعارضة لفترة طويلة جدًا.
هو فقط لم يتمكن من تحقيق ما يريد.
شخص لا يستطيع كسب الدخل الذي يريده
نفس المجموعة التي ستواجهها
ومن ناحية أخرى، الناس
قلة خبرة التحالف
وسوف ينعكس ذلك أيضًا في السياسات